bonjour vous qui regardez cette vidéo il
ya fort à parier que vous me connaissez
personne dans votre entourage qui soit
devenu moine des monastères ne font plus
partie de notre décor que pour les
ruines au bâtiment reconverti qu on en
conserve
depuis la réforme luthérienne en europe
centrale et la révolution française chez
nous l'importance des moines a
progressivement diminuer jusqu'à se
réduire à quelques monastères reculer et
à la mémoire faible d'une culture
monastique genre de chaussée aux moines
c'est par un sponsor pourtant si on
remonte dans le temps comment sait si
bien faire on trouve une institution
organisée et très importante dans
l'europe médiévale un truc de chrétiens
ça me prendra jamais le chrétienté
clairement hors sujet comme d'habitude
mais si on va du côté d'aliénor alors il
ya tonton hubert qui rentrer dans les
ordres et puis mes cousins ont donné
leur petit dernier est grand mère
marguerite est devenu monial à la fin de
sa vie et voilà une institution super
importante
[Musique]
au commencement il y avait pas de moine
forcément la vie monastique n'est pas
décrit dans le texte st on y parle par
contre de pratiquer la cèze c'est à dire
la recherche de la perfection
spirituelle mais ça passe plutôt par la
charité par contre à partir du 4e siècle
certains chrétiens d'égypte se disent
que ça serait pas mal pour renforcer
leurs croyances de partir dans le désert
fuir la société en s'inspirant de jésus
qui a vécu quarante jours dans le désert
il décide de partir seul et ça tombe
bien parce que moine vient de monoski
veut dire seule l'idée de s'isoler
d'abandonner les tentations matériel ma
culture profane et de ne plus rien faire
d'autre que lire les textes sacrés et
prier manger des fois l'autre idée des
chrétiens de l'époque et que puisqu'on
peut plus mourir pour son dieu ce qui
était une spécialité de mon temps il
devient trop facile d'être chrétien
alors disparaître du monde c'est plutôt
osé on a donc les premiers ermite qu'on
surnomme les pères du désert comme par
exemple saint-antoine saint pacôme
mais très vite des groupes se forment
autour d'eux on passe donc de
l'hermétisme vivre sa religion celle au
cénobites isme vivre sa religion en
communauté pas trop grande
car vivre en communauté n'est pas
forcément incompatible avec la recherche
de solitude des moines vivre seul veut
aussi dire vivre séparé de la société
des normes qui imposera normalement de
travailler de se marier
donc le séno british mme devient vite
très populaire parmi les ermites habite
à liège on retrouve d'ailleurs cette
forme de vie avant l'apparition du
christianisme chez les pythagoriciens et
bouddhistes les justes thérapeute et non
ce ne sont pas des juifs qui écoute vos
problèmes mais on n'a pas le temps de
s'attarder sur le premier a fondé une
communauté et saint pacôme et très vite
quand il ya une communauté chaque
s'impose on lui donne le nom d' à bas
parce que c'est une reine de la dance et
surtout parce que abba veut dire père en
grec ce qui donne ensuite le nom d'
abbey à la fin du 4e siècle il existe
donc plusieurs petites communautés en
egypte en palestine en asie mineure
et c'est dans la deuxième moitié du
quatrième siècle la vie du premier
armitt certain antoine est écrite et
diffusée en occident ce qui donne l'idée
à des occidentaux de faire pareil
imitateurs il ya aussi des voyageurs qui
reviennent d'orient et qui raconte la
cuisine locale hébergement pas terrible
et aussi ses gars qui vivent en
communauté pour la religion mais sans
faire partie de l'église trop bizarre on
voit alors en occident d army de
s'installer à la campagne dans les
forêts et les dix mots garde ils sont
dans les campagnes évidemment c'est
assez dur de transposer la vie dans les
airs en europe
à moins de se poser sur la dune du pyla
en europe il fait plus froid plus humide
donc il faut s'adapter
du coup dans les vie d'ermite qui sont
écrits par la suite on met plutôt
l'accent sur le territoire sauvage qui
est le vrai dieu d'exercices spirituels
des preuves pour les moines l'un des
premiers ermite de nos régions et saint
martin de tours qu'il commence sa vie
comme ermite avant de fonder plusieurs
monastères suivant ainsi la carrière
type de tout bon religieux est aussi
évêques est ce un bon parcours dans la
peu de traces des vrais ermite parce que
les biographies de saint écrites à
l'époque carolingienne sont pas hyper
fiable
l'archéologie n'est pas très précises
quand il s'agit de retrouver des cabane
isolée vieille de mille cinq cents ans
étonnamment grâce aux lieux d'hermitage
a testé en fermant 4000 entre le 4e et
le xviiie siècle on sait que lhermitte
sauvage pouvait surtout se rencontrer en
montagne en forêt ou encore dans les
marais où les zones inondables
c'est sympa on en trouve aussi sur des
îles comme l'île de léren qui devient
par la suite je vous le donne en mille
un monastère mais aussi dans des
anciennes villas gallo-romaines
abandonné des bâtiments en ruine des
grottes
ils ne sont pas forcément loin de tous
ni dans des lieux où l'homme n'a jamais
mis les pieds
le rider de s'isoler spirituellement et
de préférence à l'écart des chemins mais
pas forcément loin des hommes en terme
de kilomètres
et puis aspect pratique il s'installe
surtout près d'une rivière ou d'un
ruisseau et il emmène quand même avec un
petit peu de vaisselle et des livres
certains entretiennent même des ruches
leur quotidien n'est pas confortable
pour autant c'est pas le but
ils ont une alimentation sobre fait de
cueillette et beaucoup meurent
d'accidents de maladies ou de froid
j'aime particulièrement le témoignage de
moules final tous ou symboles fille pour
les intimes dont le froid faisait tomber
les ongles de ses pieds et former des
stalactites dans sa barbe
pratique pour l'apéro dès le 5ème siècle
en occident d'opti ermite disséminés ici
et là se transforme en communauté
cénobites puis en monastère au 4e siècle
les premières règles sont rédigées pour
codifier leur mode de vie
d'abord en orient puis l'occident s'y
met aussi il y en a une qui est créé par
saint pacôme de par jean cassien la plus
connue est écrite par benoît de nursie
au 4e siècle on en reparlera dans la
suite de l'histoire
l'idée de ces règles surtout en occident
est aussi de faire entrer les moines
dans le cadre de l'église parce que
jusque là ils ont surtout fait leur truc
dans leur coin et ça plaît pas trop aux
évêques qui sont un peu partagés sur la
question minutes je me retire du monde
parce que ma foi est plus pur quelle
beauté dans cette manière de vivre quel
exemple à suivre pour grégoire le grand
qui fonde les mêmes quelques monastère
les moines ne sont pas forcément des
hommes à la recherche de dieu mais aussi
des gens à la recherche de tranquillité
dans ce monde cruel et violent et des
femmes évidemment mais on fera une
partie rien que pour elle parce que son
temps même un petit peu à part dans le
domaine de l'église sans blague
bref les règles monastiques s'imposent
chaque monastère ayant sa red bull a sur
la part des ses au travail à cultura la
prière le rythme de la journée et la
discipline etc
nous arrivons donc au 6e siècle où il ya
déjà près de 200 monastère en gaule à
cette époque durant tout le haut
moyen-âge
la plupart des moines reste des laïcs
n'ont pas de formation religieuse et on
trouve seulement un ou deux prêtres
parmi eux pour qu une abbaye soient
fondées il faut au moins un gars qui s'y
connaissent qu'ils puissent apprendre la
liturgie aux autres les abbayes sont
donc aussi des centres de formation à la
vie monastique une nouveauté apparaît
cependant au 6ème siècle les
aristocrates ou souverains comment sa
patronne et des fondations monastiques
en donnant l'argent le terrain ou les
deux les rois sigismond childebert
premier et les rênes radegonde et bruno
font des monastères même si la grande
majorité reste à l'initiative des verts
où le religieux l'idée est d'étaler sa
générosité et éventuellement d'avoir un
coin tranquille où prendre sa retraite à
la fin de sa vie le monachisme n'est
donc plus vu comme un arrachement à la
société et commence à remplir un rôle
social important
les moines prix pour le salut de l'âme
de tout surtout pour ceux qui ont payé
monastère et tout le monde sera soul et
veni vidi vici
ils peuvent remplir quelques autres
rôles comme éduquer les enfants de la
famille placés les femmes qu'on n'arrive
pas à marier ou les vieux ou servir de
lieu de mémoire pour les ancêtres
un autre intérêt est de doter les
territoires d'une meilleure organisation
administrative via les monastères
classiques parfois aussi les raisons de
la fondation d'un monastère sont le
bonheur pour fêter la naissance d'un
héritier ou leur gré l'abbaye de
goebbels berg à vos souhaits et fondée
par frédéric disant berg sur le lieu où
il a assassiné l'archevêque de cologne
son oncle pardon ses monastères restent
attachés et en grande partie sous le
contrôle de la famille qui les a fondé
alors que les autres monastères reste
sous le contrôle des évêques mais
commencent à réclamer et obtenir de plus
en plus de privilèges à partir du 7e
siècle habite saint gall indépendante à
la fin du 6e siècle de nouveaux moines
arrive dans le game ils sont instruits
ils sont intelligents ils respectent une
assez stricte
les irlandais tout commence par saint
colomban encore un aristocrate devenu
moine du monastère de bangor après douze
ans de prières et autres trucs de moine
il demande l'autorisation à son abbé de
partir sur le continent avec deux
copains et d'exporter des coutumes
irlandaise partout où il passe non pas
celle là il se rend à la cour
mérovingienne burgondes et parcourt
ainsi la gueule pendant 25 ans en
fondant quelques monastères sur son
passage comme celui de luxe de bobbio
wilmer en 615 à sa mort la baie de
beaulieu demande à un moine de faire le
chemin inverse jusqu en irlande pour
recueillir des témoignages sur sa vie et
écrire une biographie de saint colomban
qui devient un best-seller son action et
celle de ses disciples permet la
fondation de 250 à 300 monastère et
l'établissement pour la première fois
deux monastères régis par les mêmes
règles et respectent tous le modèle
irlandais basé sur une forte discipline
et l'importance de la cèze et non ce
n'est pas la chaise prononcé avec un
zézaiement cette idée de monastères
unifiée sous les mêmes règles
fait son chemin au septième siècle
jusque là c'était le fondateur du
monastère qui rédigeait ses règles en
s'inspirant des anciennes de saint
pacôme et compagnie mais on les remet à
nyon à sa sauce les règles exposé le
code de vie religieuse de l'abbaye
l'organisation de la vie quotidienne les
relations avec le monde extérieur et été
complété par des coutumes et des statuts
qui précise l organisation matérielle de
l'abbaye il existait donc une trentaine
de communautés différentes jusqu'à ce
que saint benoît réapparaissent dans
l'histoire j'ai déjà parlé de benoît de
nursie en début de vidéo
il venait d'une famille sénatoriales
italienne mais qui tout pour devenir
ermite puis fondé quelques monastères au
début du vième siècle il termine ces
jours au mont cassin et rédige la règle
bénédictine les règles assez courtes qui
prône une division de la vie des moines
en trois temps la méditation et prière
individuelle lectio divina le temps de
prière collective opus dei et le travail
manuel
je ne connais pas ce coup là sans blague
et met aussi en avant le rôle de la baie
qui doit être choisi par les moines et
l'importance de la prière collective ce
qui montre que pas mal de moines entre
encore au monastère analphabètes
cela nécessite la dotation en
bibliothèque en école et scriptorium qui
font des monastères bénédictins des
lieux de culture le dernier point
important est la stabilité du moine qui
doit passer toute sa vie dans un
monastère
contrairement aux irlandais qui aimez
partir parcourir les routes pour aller
vendre du rêve ailleurs sa règle n'a pas
un retentissement très important jusqu'à
ce que le pape grégoire le grand rédigé
une biographie de saint benoît au début
du 7e siècle à partir de la soul
influence du pape et des carolingiens la
règle bénédictine se répand partout ce
qui donne les monastères bénédictins
grégoire le grand est aussi celui qui
évangélise l'angleterre et y impose
cette règle des carolingiens à tort
cette règle charlemagne fait de la
fondation des monastères un privilège
royal et en 1816 la règle bénédictine
est imposée pour tous charlemagne puis
louis le pieux nomment eux mêmes les
abbés des monastères royaux souvent des
gens de la famille ce qui leur vaut
quelques critiques de la part des moines
sous les carolingiens le nombre de
monastères passe de 200 au début du 7e
siècle à plus de 600 au début du
neuvième siècle
le recrutement se fait soit par vocation
soit pardon d'un enfant au monastère
qu'on appelle oblation et cette très
forte expansion des monastères entraîne
la formation de ville autour des
monastères la ville de saint riquier par
exemple est construite autour d'une
abbaye de 300 moines et compte 7000
habitants ce qui est assez balèze points
à l'époque cette belle expansion qui
nous montre que même le haut moyen-âge
n'était pas un temps obscurs merci bien
est toutefois freinée par les
destructions hongroise sarrasine et
normandes le pouvoir central diminue à
cause de ces invasions le pouvoir des
évêques aussi et jusqu'au 10ème siècle
l'humeur n'est plus trop à la fondation
de nouveau monastère mais plutôt à la
sauvegarde des meubles les monastères
existants conservent leur rôle de
formation culturelle et d'administration
du territoire
mais c'est tout puisque cette première
partie était déjà bien longue
les moines du 10e au xvème siècle feront
l'objet d'une autre vidéo c'est pas pour
vous disais mais on abordera le retour
des ermites une nouvelle organisation
que rayonnante que jamais des croupes
mendiant au bord de l'hérésie et les
femmes
ah mais oui tiens avant de conclure
parlons des femmes bizarrement je
trouvais moins d'informations sur les
femmes que sur les hommes donc ça va
aller plutôt vite même si les premiers
moines sont des hommes les femmes sont
rapidement attiré par cette idée de
consacrer leur vie à la religion mais
les modalités sont plutôt différente
elles font voeu de virginité et passent
leur vie recluse chez elle à lire la
bible toute la journée et à s'occuper
des pauvres de temps en temps dès le
4ème siècle des évêques reconnaissent
leurs engagements et les consacre comme
épouse du christ elles sont alors
autorisés à porter un voile comme les
femmes mariées certaines chrétienne
fonde aussi des monastères familiaux en
invitant toutes les jeunes filles et
veuves qui veulent les rejoindre pour
vivre recluse ensemble des communautés
féminines apparaissent 6e siècle les
premiers monastères féminin qui adopte
alors des règles féminine cette façon
les règles c'est féminin
non mais oh il existe différents types
de monastères féminin des abbayes
indépendante qui sont sous la tutelle de
l'évêque des monastères féminin qui sont
des branches féminine de monastères
masculin existant déjà ou des monastères
double comme fontevraud qui a deux
branches en gros les moines d'un côté
les moniales de l'autre les monastères
féminins sont quand même un peu moins
nombreux
l'unique on abordera dans la prochaine
vidéo compte 880 monastère dont 20 ans
pour les femmes
la règle bénédictine version femme est
rédigé en 1817 et réduit au maximum les
contacts avec l'extérieur
même la baisse doit demander
l'autorisation de l'évêque pour se
déplacer les monastères féminin plaisent
à l'aristocratie qui fait des dons des
cadeaux parce que comme ça s'ils savent
pas quoi faire de leur fille ou de leurs
veuves y aura toujours une place pour
elle par contre ses monastères ne sont
pas exclusivement féminin ce que le
fameux savent pas tout faire non plus il
ya des prêtres pour assurer l'office des
sergents pour la sécurité des prévôts
pour rendre la justice sur le territoire
de l'abbaye tout ça elles savent pas
faire un les femmes le seul ordre
vraiment fondée par des femmes et celui
des brigittines qui apparaît au 14e
siècle
sacré brigitte enfin au deuxième siècle
apparaissent les béguines surtout dans
les villes du nord qui à la base se
rapproche pas mal des pratiques
religieuses du 4e siècle
elle mène un mode de vie ascétique et
pratiquer la charité tout en restant
chez elle tranquille je les comprends
tout à fait et ça me plaît pas trop l
église qui du coup n'a aucun contrôle
sur elle certaines finissent par fonder
des monastères d'autre part être brûlé
pour hérésie en 1311 le pape interdit le
béguinage mais il errait autorisé par la
suite du coup et puisqu'il reste
énormément de choses à dire sur les
moines durant le bas moyen-âge 10e 15e
siècle si vous n'êtes pas trop à l'aise
avec les termes on va s'arrêter là dans
le prochain épisode on parlera des
nouveaux ordres qui apparaissent durant
cette période je ne sais déjà ce pôle et
cluny est aussi un petit peu plus de
comment vivaient les moines comment est
ce qu'ils vivent et qu'est ce qu'il
faisait leur journée pourquoi est ce que
dans les films ils passent leur temps à
recopier des livres en faisant des
coloriages etc
avant de vous quitter je tiens à vous
rappeler parce que j'ai pense pas
souvent que j'ai deux plateformes sur
lesquelles vous pouvez me financer si
jamais vous voulez mais vais peut-être
un jour vivre de ma chaîne
on ne sait pas il ya tipi déjà donc qui
est plutôt connue glaciers que vous
pouvez faire des dons mensuels au des
dons unique et il ya eu un type qui est
plus récent et c'est le même principe
sauf que vous pouvez aussi si vous
voulez juste regarder des pubs et ça me
rapporte de l'argent
indirectement l'argent des pubs voilà
sinon il nous nourrit pas non non non je
vous dis donc à dans trois semaines pour
la deuxième partie au revoir je suis le
roi de la france
royaume et à mes pieds de la puissance
je suis au plus haut et pourtant je dois
vous enviez je voudrais devenir un mois
ce serait merveilleux vivre pareil aux
autres mois loin des sujets ennuyeux oop
nouveaux pays d'auge audrey priait comme
vous mais dit comme vous faire comme
vous tous un homme comme moi
pourrais je crois être parfois bien plus
chrétien vous pourtant crois moi je suis
pas dupe s'il forme d ab c'est que je
désire le moyen d'être à moines de cluny
dit moir secret pour être à moins est ce
vraiment si mystérieux pour moi faire
des enluminures ce serait merveilleux au
web et de copines aux gens de prier
comme vous et pas chez tabou faire comme
vous tous car je lave ou un homme comme
moi c'est vrai je crois peut devenir
comme vous